- [Man] I was going to ask
you Snapchat or Instagram,
what do you do?
- Both.
- [Man] And we kinda
figured you'd say that.
So, what do you do first?
- Both.
- [Man] At the same time?
- Yep.
- [Man] You're not going
Snapchat then taking that
video and putting
it on Instagram?
- Honestly,
that's just a cadence.
That's just a moment in time.
That's a however you feel,
which one do you like.
But anybody who's
listening right now
that wants to make
something happen,
you're gonna build the
next biggest clothing line,
both.
- [Man] Right.
- You wanna get some new
customers for your
bakery shop? Both.
You want to get a job interview
at a social media shop? Both.
If you have ambition, your
actions have to match that
and too many people are
just not putting in the work.
Their mouth is way ahead
of their fucking actions.
Like really? You're gonna be the
greatest NBA player of all time?
Why because you think you got a
little handle on the weekends?
You need to shoot 15,000 free
throws before school every day.
To me the answer is
both and it's not even,
when people, when business,
if you're a normal person,
if my brother-in-law is like,
"What should I do for my life?"
I don't care one or the other.
But if you're a businessperson
or you have ambitions
or you want to run for office
or whatever you want to do,
both, always, and--
- [Man] Use every avenue.
- and Twitter and Facebook--
- and YouTube and SoundCloud.
And, and, and, and both.
(light music)